[Musique]
alexandre c'est la surprise est en grève
ou pas c'est tellement jubilatoire de la
revoir dans la saison 2 ans une vraie
folle prête à tout donc d'autant plus
prête à tout pour gagner mais pour
gagner pour marc parent qui
tu te ridiculise devant toulouse tu me
fous la route dans la saison 2 voilà
encore plus folle où le premier qui
bouge sera éliminé éliminé du jeu alex
et moi je vous plains pas elle peut le
faire que du stade avec sens là je vais
te dire un truc
oui c'est quitte ou pour marc les gogos
qui était assez drôle c'est que je je
porte marque sur mes épaules havrais qui
fait d'un peu plus de 80 kg et mais pour
elle tout c'est tout à fait normal c'est
elle qui veut porte sur son dos et je
penche tout le trajet fort qu'il faut
treize ans c'est assez hilarant pajiba
pieds là tout est romancé tron s'est
prolongé bien à pied
la première saison quand on quand on va
tourner je me souviens qu'une fois j'en
attends m'a dit
il faut que tu te rappelles mois
peut-être pour rien dire je sais pas il
faut qu'on trouve un truc et ça là que
ça a commencé mais c'était pas forcément
écrit
[Applaudissements]
et ça c'était génial la deuxième saison
il y avait un truc hockey se dire
alexandra jeu faut pas que je repars de
la même chose
c'est moussa yak avec le personnage de
marc je peux m jonathan cohen sur mes
ongles vu que ça fait ben moi qu'on a
commencé le tournage il ya il ya déjà
des doigts où il ait pu et donc je me
parla je parle à mes dix marques et en
fait j'ai l'impression que marc encore
mourir dont je pleure et voilà c'est du
coup on peut faire des scènes un peu
comme ça
c'est génial je joue je boude pas mon
plaisir quoi
un petit je me suis racheté la
telenovela city puisque alexandra n'est
pas censé être là bas et donc c'est
comme si c'était marcon quand marc
alexandre à ce qu'on sait paris sera
peut-être à travers d'autres gens et
donc je serai confessions je suis mal
qu'on chante et ça tombe mal parce que
marcos et pas marc gouton ocz va te
[ __ ] donc qu enfin jonathan par honda
marco on n'a pas encore tourné le début
de la flamme
chez veux que tu m'as manière jamais je
t'appartiens prix thomas pas le cas déjà
on parle de marco et puis me voilà
cherchent-elles acteur et
il faut que ce soit toi qui lui joue
ennemie c'est fou parce qu'on en a parlé
ce matin
et je sais pas bref il ne fait pas pour
sa part que puissant minutes
elle part avec moscou qui m'a aimée
comme eux comme personne ne va jamais
aimé mais voilà l'amour bel et bien se
commande pas bon mais elle par un bug
marque mais bon mais alexandra le sera
elle partira jamais vraiment qu'est ce
que tu accepterais que j'allais vivre
cet amour par coup ben oui bien sûr
il comble
[Applaudissements]
allez salut à vous
allez pas
[Musique]